[Music]
a lawsuit accusing britain's prince
andrew of sexual abuse goes before a
federal judge today here in new york
queen elizabeth's middle son has always
denied these allegations and he's not
been charged with any crimes holly
williams reports on today's pre-trial
conference and the effort by andrew's
lawyers to just throw out the lawsuit
prince andrew's friendship with sex
offender jeffrey epstein has already
brought scandal to the royal family now
a court will decide whether he was
properly served with legal documents in
a civil suit alleging sexual assault
spencer coovin is an attorney for nine
epstein accusers though not the
plaintiff in the case against prince
andrew you likely aren't going to see
prince andrew anytime soon in court and
even if the court were allowed prince
andrew to be
deposed and he would have to give a
deposition
likely a deposition like that would be
under seal and most people will not see
that until the case where you go to
trial if at all
prince andrew's accuser is virginia
roberts jeffrey interviewed by gail king
last year
he needs to be held accountable we need
to show the world that
the rich and the mighty can fall too
she claims jeffrey epstein and his
alleged accomplice gulen maxwell forced
her to have sex with their friend the
prince on several occasions including
when she was a minor
after epstein's arrest on new charges
and suicide in 2019 maxwell is now
awaiting trial accused of sex
trafficking underage girls which she
denies including jeffrey's allegation i
have no recollection of ever meeting
this lady
none whatsoever
in an interview with the bbc in 2019
prince andrews said he'd had no sexual
contact with jeffrey and even suggested
this photograph apparently showing them
together might be doctored
but in jeffree he has a determined
accuser he knows what he's done virginia
as a victim has been been very vocal
about wanting the world to know her
truth and what happened to her so i
would suspect that that may end up being
one of the biggest sticking points as
opposed to money
so far there's been no official comment
from buckingham palace or from prince
andrew the case can only go forward
giving the prince 21 days to respond if
the court finds that he was properly
served with the legal documents and we
understand that his lawyers dispute that
because the papers were given to a
police officer at prince andrews
residence and sent by email
gail
and that is the question thank you very
much holly williams reporting from
buckingham palace